life track and never look
backs and simply learn to get
ahead Danish a civil engineer turned
data scientist who decided to Simply
learn
possible with a course from a premier
[Music]
University true champion who upskilled
to win
big how big a massive hike that
transformed my life Danish change gears
pretty early in the race but PR wanted
to explore more to get ahead isar simply
learn from mechanical engineering to a
data analyst and a podcaster in his free
time career transformation bro simply
learn industry expert
live dat
expert
with a well structured course it felt
like a piece of cake that is simply
awesome what's also awesome is that
longin didn't choose a quick fix he just
added data science into the mix how did
you change the game worked on real
industry problems to become the real
deal a joint family a regular job
responsibilities but nothing could stop
nin from getting ahead what an
allrounder de night with flexible
learning you can always make it right
passion
situation
n you to will find your way to get ahead
when you simply
learn simply learn get ahead with simply
[Music]
learn
recording in
progress
hello hey Mark hi good morning good
afternoon good
evening uh good evening from my side uh
so I've actually given you the panelist
access so you can turn on your camera
and I can I think uh hear you pretty
clear as well uh we'll be starting with
session few minutes meanwhile uh so I'm
rashak Khan I'm your host for today's
webinar and I am thrilled to host you
today and drop us a hello and let us
know where are you T tuning in from uh
you can let us know in chat here you can
type in your name and the place you're
joining us from uh let's start a bit
right before we start I can see a lot of
folks are settling in and joining in
right now we'll just give it few minutes
more before we start the session the
free digital marketing master class and
we already have a speaker here with us
Mark
Camp Mark where are joining us
from I'm joining you from
Malaysia oh interesting nice how's the
weather
there huh how's the weather
there very consistent 30 degrees every
day
okay okay we can see a lot of
introductions coming in on chat here so
I can see Samuel has joined from Nigeria
I can see Gabriel has joined from Ghana
I can see n has joined from USA I can
see Luca from croia I can see Jean from
Rwanda I can see uh some folks have
joined from katur India Romania
Hyderabad so we have gotten a lot of
folks from different different parts of
the world so that's great uh so let the
global conversation begin before we
start so keep the introductions coming
in we'll just start uh in few minutes uh
the free JS marketing master class and
we'll be talking about how you can
Master the art of digital branding just
like toast and also there'll be a
program preview uh by P
University in digital
marketing okay I can see a lot of
introductions coming in and I can see a
lot of folks have joined from different
different parts of the world so that's
great uh please keep the introductions
coming in in case you have just joined
now we just doing a quick round of
introductions it's always a good good
way to uh Network right these events
right right before these events uh so
why not just introduce yourself on the
chart here and just uh interact with the
folks who have joined here so
yeah
okay I can see a lot of folks have given
their instructions on chat so again like
once again welcome everyone I am rosha
Khan I'm your host for today's webinar
and we'll be taking the free digital
marketing CL master class and talking
about how you can Master the art of
digital branding like just like toast
also you'll be covering a program
preview by Perdue uh on postc program
digital marketing so moving on before we
start uh while you're settling I'll just
clear a few ground rules here uh so you
need to put on your questions in the Q&A
box if you have any queries so just to
clear that out uh right now we are
basically having a conversation on the
chat box webinar chat box and just
beside that there is a small q& box so
you can just click on that and go and
submit your question there only make
sure that it is related to uh digital
marketing uh so we can because this
webinar is about digital marketing so
that's all is the expectation here and I
will make sure that all of your
questions are answered by a speaker Mark
campign here uh also this session is
being recorded so you can expect a
followup email with recording link
webinar certificate and a bonus offer as
well for attending this webinar for the
program which be talking about you know
once we are done with the master class
uh also to request a proof of attendance
for this webinar you need to enter your
full name in the post webinar survey so
the post webinar survey pops up when the
webinar ends uh so this webinar is of
160 minutes duration and once it ends
you will see a post webinar survey where
you just need to basically put in your
full name which you want to see in your
webinar certificate for this one so I
hope uh that makes it clear for you
folks please do let us know if you have
any questions feel free to do that uh
try to put on your questions in the q&
walk that's all because as you can see
we're getting a lot of messages on chat
here and we might miss it and we would
love to answer all of your
questions so once again welcome everyone
uh this program is powered by simply
learn World's Online number one boot
camp uh we are very proud that we have
been the digital skills training space
for all almost 13 years now and uh we
have professionally trained over 5
million plus Professionals in over 150
plus countries and we are very proud of
that uh so let's start with a quick poll
uh before we start the free uh digital
marketing master class uh so let's get
to know each other a little better so
you can see a quick hole on your screen
here so uh please do let us know how
many years of experience do you
currently have so you can see four quick
options on the poll which you see on
your screen here um the first one being
you have less than two years of
experience you can select that that one
if it is the most suitable to you uh the
second one 2 to five years of experience
uh third one 6 to 10 years of experience
and the last one more than uh 10 years
of experience so I can see the polls
moving on already so that's great we
have gotten a very active audience here
and also if you're done with the voting
for The Experience part you can always
go and get give your introductional chat
so uh there's always time for a little
bit of conversation or chat here right
so why
not awesome awesome I'll just keep this
poll alive for 10 seconds more because I
can see most of the folks have already
shared how many years of experience do
they have I'm just waiting for few more
folks I'll give them like 5 Seconds more
uh for them to uh basically go and tell
us how many years of experience do they
have in this quick poll before we start
the free d marketing Master
Class awesome I think I can see most of
the folks have already shared their
responses here so I'll just give five
seconds more so five 4 3 2 1 let me
quickly end the poll and share the
result with you folks so as you can see
uh we have almost 72% of the folks who
have less than two years of experience
uh we have uh 133% of the folks who have
two to of experience we have few of the
folks who have 6 to 10% of experience
and uh similar amount of folks who have
more than 10 years of experience so
thank you so much for sharing that with
us now moving on uh moving on we'll talk
about the agenda of the session today uh
so as I said we'll be getting to know
more about you how we can help you out
better with your career in digital
marketing and also we'll be doing a
project demonstration on how you can
Master the art of fril brand in to reach
new customers just like toast uh and
also we'll be going through a program
introduction uh for postc program in
digital marketing by purdum and taking
you through the enrollment steps for
that and also there'll be a special
duration for the Q&A part so uh as I
said you need to put down your questions
in the Q&A box that is just beside the
chat in case you have any questions and
please keep it related to digital
marketing that will be great and also um
in case we'll try to take as many
questions as possible during the the
project demo uh if it is related to the
project demonstration which we are doing
if you have any questions I would say
actively go and put down your questions
in the Q&A box because Mark will be
opening the basically keeping the Q&A
Box open on the side and taking those
questions uh you know if if the time
allows and uh we'll basically then
obviously there'll be a special duration
for the Q&A part in case in case your
question is not answered so don't panic
just have a little patience with us
we'll try to take as many questions as
possible throughout the session so thank
you so much I think uh we already have a
speaker here with us uh Mark campen who
will be taking us to the free digital
marketing master class uh mark would you
like to give us uh your introduction to
the crowd here sure sure good uh good
morning good afternoon everybody and um
I am Mark um there was no um choice in
the little questionnaire just now of
more than 40y year experience but I
would be the only person who would score
on that um I started working in
1981 with IBM and most of you were not
even born then um IBM in Amsterdam I'm
Dutch and um computers the personal
computer wasn't even invest invented the
word digital marketing was not on
people's radar screen and how things
have changed over those 4 years and and
I've been um involved in all those uh
PES I worked um in the European markets
I lived in Silicon Valley in San
Francisco for a few years I was one of
the first to demo the internet in
1995 and um got into digital marketing
and social media from the early
2000s um about 14 years ago I started my
own little training company um training
people and businesses in digital
marketing and social
media and I think it's now about five
years ago that I started working
with we simply learn and um I can't say
that I trained a million people for
simply learn but um I've trained quite a
few um I've been running digital
marketing training personer now for five
six years and it's a it's a wonderful
team to work with and I'm looking
forward to to continue doing that so
welcome and hopefully in the today's
session I'm
going to give you a quick taster of what
the digital marketing training in that
you would attend with simply learn what
that would give you so that's my uh my
quick introduction
and uh I think there was another
question coming
um Russia I don't know if you want me to
go into this question or no no no uh I
think uh we'll take questions maybe Mark
in sometime uh thank you so much for
your introduction and uh we'll be
starting the project demonstration
session uh now uh so we'll be talking
about how you can Master the art of
digital branding just to reach new
customers just like toast and this will
be a project demonstration so we won't
be doing the whole whole project we'll
be doing a demonstration sort of just to
give you an idea and uh over to you
mark okay um to be able to do the demo
can you can I share my screen sure sure
you can go ahead and share your screen
yeah you have the access you can do that
yeah okay please do let me know when you
want me to share back the screen you can
let me know yeah yeah yeah I will I will
tell you sure sure okay hopefully people
can see my screen
now uh can I just have a quick
confirmation that you can see my my
screen yes I think uh I we have gotten
one response here yes yes we getting a
lot of here on chat yeah okay so you
would see here the screen of um of toast
yeah so here you see a website of a real
company and it is a company in women's
wear in fashion Men's Wear house and
home they do a lot of things and like
you maybe want to do maybe you already
have you want to start your own business
yep and um obviously you want a website
to promote your own business and that is
sort of the starting point for the uh
the the master's program of course that
you will learn how to develop your own
website and all from a marketing
perspective yeah and and then of course
you need to understand once you have
your website then what yeah and
basically it comes down to a very simple
question yeah if I go to Google and I
search for toast
fashion
retailer yeah then what do people find
on
Google yeah and that is a very important
part of what you will learn in this
program yeah how can you present
yourselves online how do you make sure
that Google will find you yeah how do
you make sure that you you
control what people will read about you
when they search for you on Google or on
Bing yeah the
Microsoft search engine and how can you
influence that yeah and that is a very
important part of digital
marketing yeah and uh in digital
marketing terms we call this search
engine
optimization yeah that when people
search for you or search for for
instance the word women fashion in uh in
Google that you are showing high up in
the search
results okay and that is what toast has
done as well yeah they have optimized
their websites for Google that they show
up high now they have optimized it in
two ways there is here you see for toast
you see sponsored which is
advertising Y and that is a very
important part as well in the digital
marketing landscape so we will be
talking about that in the master's
program as well but then there is the
non-paid yeah the those listings in the
Google search where you don't have to
pay but you show up high in search
results okay so that is what basically
this demo that I'm doing is basically
all about yeah you search for your
website and then what it comes down to
how do you
show on Google how can people find you
on Google and how can you promote
yourself on Google that is uh the
basically the essence of the questions
that are being answered in the digital
marketing
training okay so keep that in mind yeah
these three questions how to show how to
find how to promote now if you then go a
bit further into this yeah if I go back
to the toast
website what you will then see there are
a lot of digital marketing tools
available that you can use to help you
with answering these questions for
instance here is a tool which is called
the
SEO um tools yep and if I click on this
while this website is open it gives me
basic information basic SEO
information yeah search engine
optimization information about these
websit yeah you see how many people are
visiting the website an estimation yeah
it talks about
keywords yeah and also you can analyze
the page and here you see what post has
done really well they make sure that
they have a very good page title for the
website yeah and you see that page title
up here you see here toast women's
wear men's wear and functional home
wear so that is what you specify in your
website that Google picks that up in the
um when it uh when it sort of indexes
your
website same here with the
description yeah same here with meta
Texs with headings so they've done a
really good job with optimizing their
website for the sear engins and that is
um and you're going to practice this as
well yeah so and what you will also
learn that a key aspect of this um
search engine
optimization is the concept of
keywords yeah and we're going to spend
quite some time in the program on using
keywords on finding keywords for your
digital marketing for your cention
optimization and for your um for your
for your
advertising yeah so if I go back to the
website yeah and go back to this little
tool here yeah then here you see keyword
suggestions yeah so for instance I can
put in the term women uh
fashion yeah and I don't want
um
this I just want a to z country United
States and now give me keyword
[Music]
suggestions yes so basically you are
need to tell Google what keywords are
relevant for
you yeah and again this is just a little
taster of what search engine
optimization is all about and we're
going to and we're using this toast as
an example on how they have done this
yes so here you see yeah what the type
of keywords that you could use to
promote the business but you need more
information here are just the ideas for
the keywords yeah so women fashion dress
um what's it women fashion Nova dress
women Fashion online hundreds if not
thousands of keywords so I can go take
for instance a keyword here women
fashion handbag I can actually go here
to Google click here on Google and then
I can see the results when people search
for that
word yeah and here you see that it for
instance now we don't see um toast
showing up in the search results so
maybe this is not an important keyword
for
them yes so
once you understand that concept of the
keywords and again toast has done that
very well yeah you need to do two things
you create a list of keyword
ideas and then you're going to research
two things you're going to research how
many people are searching for those
products and how difficult is it to
compete for that prod in other words how
many other companies are trying to use
that keyword to show up in the search
rankings and that is what we call the
process of keyword
research yeah and there are lots of
tools that you can use for that one very
simple tool and again we're going into
that in more detail when we go in the uh
in the live sessions is a a tool called
keywords
everywhere yeah and see what happens if
I switch that
on yeah I can then do a refresh of this
search
page yeah and now see what happens all
of a sudden I now have extra information
under my search results so I see here
the word women's fashion
handbags yeah there are only
320 people are searching for this word
per
month yeah and here you also have an
idea about the competition level yeah so
competition level is quite low for this
words yeah so you're going to capture
all those details yeah and you're going
to get additional ideas yeah so here you
see if I now scroll down
I see also you see here in the Google
search page I see related keywords so
for instance designer handback sale
Outlet so here I see
8,100 so that is a lot more volume in
the UK yeah than
320 for the women's fashion handbag yeah
so with this tool I can get lots of
ideas for keyword words that I want to
focus
on yeah and um I get ideas about the
search
volumes yeah and the competitive
difficulty for those
keywords okay so that is basically what
I'm explaining here to you is the
process of keyword research which is a
fundamental part of digital
marketing okay okay and what I will then
give you in the workshops I will give
you lots of
templates yeah and uh here you see a
template in Google Sheets that you can
use to do your keyword
research yeah so here you see um all the
keywords that you have found in your
initial keyword word research this is an
example for a shoe online shoe
store yeah and then for all these words
take here women's shoes you're going to
look at the average monthly searches and
you're going to look at the competition
level and then you're going to do some
very magic things Y and then you come to
a final list of keywords that are going
to be your strategic keywords that you
are going to be using in your digital
marketing yeah and in the training we
will be using
toast yeah where we're going to exercise
this to put a similar spreadsheet
together for
them okay so that is in a
nutshell how toast has been able to have
a very good presence on Google for their
Master for the keywords that are
relevant for them and that really sort
of kickstarted their digital marketing
their um their social media their
advertising and uh email marketing and
um as you will learn at the basis of all
this is the concept of keyword research
amongst other things that you will will
learn but for me keyword analysis is a
very important part of
this okay well that's a very interesting
uh Mark I think something to look
forward to the project demo uh I think
uh someone has asked on the chat how do
we get a copy of the key keyword
research guide I think you told them
that you'll be sharing it so uh can you
clear that
up yes yes so um when when I run these
sessions yeah I will be sharing those
templates with you yeah and every
instructor um they they probably use
their own methodologies I have developed
this methodology that I will be sharing
with my students oh interesting
interesting I think we'll talk about
this project demonstration uh more uh
but obviously be talking about the
program and so many other projects we
have in the program after we are done
with the project demo
uh so uh I think uh would you like me to
share back my the screen yeah sure yeah
let me
uh stop sharing there we go let me
quickly share the screen uh before we
start we just have a quick poll question
for folks here uh just to understand why
are the attending this webinar today so
you can see a quick poll on your screen
here uh where where you can see options
of on basically why are you attending
this webinar today uh you can see four
options here in case the four options
does not answer your uh basically uh you
know relate to your what you basically
are looking for you can let us know on
chat also so that is okay so I just read
out the options for you and give you 10
seconds um basically to just select
these options and this is a multiple
choice poll you can select multiple
options there can be multiple reasons
also right to attend this project
demonstration uh so the first one is I'm
looking to Pi a a digital marketing
professional second one is I want to
learn a new new skill third one I'm here
to understand if digital marketing is
easy to learn and the last one I'm
interested in working on new projects
for my portfolio so I can see the polls
moving in already and uh I'll just give
like 10 seconds more for the few of the
folks who have not shared basically why
are they attending this webinar today uh
so I would encourage everyone to just
quickly go and vote for this this will
give us a very good understanding
basically what are you looking for when
you are ATT attend this webinar today
and also how to make it better as well
right so you can let us know in chat as
well okay awesome I think uh I can see
most of the folks have already shared
I'll just give five seconds more folks
uh for the poll and I'll close it and
then I'll start with the project
demonstration which which Mark will be
taking over so 5 4 3 2 1 let me quickly
end the poll and also share the results
as well so uh Mark as we can see that uh
50% of the folks have voted for two
options uh the first one being I'm
looking to uh to become a digital
marketing professional that's great
you're at the right place uh and also I
think we've got an equal amount of half
of the vs for I want to learn a new
skill I think uh you definitely will uh
get some value adding uh you know skill
from this session uh basically something
to look forward to and also I think we
have gotten a lot of votes where I'm
interested on working on new projects my
you I think you're at the right place we
are doing a project demonstration at
least that will give you a little bit
idea you know in which direction to go
for and few of them have voted for I am
here to understand if digital marketing
is to easy to learn I think the session
will give you a little bit understanding
for that we hope so uh so I think uh
Moving On Let's uh start with the
project demonstration over to you mark
please let me know if how do you want to
navigate the slides you can let me
know um I've just done these slides so I
think and I've uh I've closed the um I'm
done with the the project demonstration
sure sure sure I think uh I I'll just
quickly uh browse through these slides
for the for also just for them to have a
look uh so as we can see the Google
search here which Mark has already shown
and also uh in the next slide we can
see the analytics here the
keywords sorry you were saying something
yeah I'm happy to quickly summarize what
I said here so remember the the
importance of keywords yeah we talked
about and I showed you some tools that
um can help you with the with finding uh
data about the keywords yeah so we
looked at this SEO Scout tool and we
looked at keywords everywhere in Google
if you go to the next
slide yeah so here you see the three
tools that we are using in this case SEO
Scout where you can analyze the page
where you can get ideas for keywords
yeah then there of course is Google
where do the keywords show up in the
program you will also get lots and lots
of Google related tools gools directly
developed by Google that you can use in
your digital marketing yep and then
there is a keywords everywhere a tool
that I show do a little plugin in Google
where you get search volumes keyword
difficulties and um and related keywords
yeah so if you go to the next
slide so here you see the keyword
template that um I showed you where in
the in during the program um you will
receive um multiple templates that you
can use to schedule your digital
marketing activities whether it's
strategy templates in this case keyword
templates advertising templates so um
that is uh I think that is where you get
a lot of value from this program where
you get lots of handson tools that you
can use once you start practicing what
you've learned in real life as it were
uh thank you so much M for taking us to
to the summary of the project
demonstration once again uh so we have
talked about basically what exactly this
project demonstration you know holds uh
when basically it comes to digital
marketing digital branding so uh what
exactly is stopping you uh from BEC a
digital marketing expert you can see a
quick poll on your screen here so we
want to know what is the biggest
challenge here when you basically are
trying to Aspire for a digital marketing
career or trying to become a digital
marketing expert you know whatever you
want to say so you can see four quick
options here this is a multiple choice
question so you can select multiple
options here if these particular options
do not cover the uh basically answer you
have you can let us know on chat or in
the Q&A box here as well feel free to do
that I just read out those options for
you because I can see folks have already
started sharing their challenges here
with us so I'll just read out these
options for you uh for folks who are
still looking through it so are the
first one me I can't find a fully
comprehensive curriculum program and the
second one I don't have the Practical
exposure need to become job ready and
the third one I find it difficult to
learn from pre-recorded videos and the
fourth one why Works couldn't B anow me
enough time for learning so I can see uh
I think almost 80% of the folks have
already shared their responses that's
great youve gotten a really great uh you
know active audience here and I can see
some uh basically confusion going on
chat here uh I think someone basically
was not able to hear the audio so uh
it's okay sometimes you know internet
malfunctions also happen folks uh you
can just maybe you know quickly read
join or check your mic it's totally okay
and also please don't panic the
recording of the session will be shared
after this uh session over uh over a
basically post webinar email so you can
go through the recording also once again
in case you have missed something so
don't worry about
that okay I think uh most of the folks
have already shared their concern let me
just quickly end the poll and share the
results with you uh so as we can see
here the biggest concern here is uh
basically I can't find a program with a
fully comprehensive curriculum and I can
see uh basically I think second biggest
concern here as well uh I wouldn't get
the Practical exposure I need to become
job ready and I can see 33% of the folks
have voted for why work schedule won't
allow me enough time for Learning and
few of the folks I voted for I find it
difficult to learn from pre-recorded
videos so uh taking you to the program
introduction now uh so produce a
postgraduate program in digital
marketing which is co-created by meta
blueprint and also has a content
provider by Harvard uh business
publishing education uh in this program
you get a comprehensive curriculum with
an industry aligned learning path and
also you get access to integrated case
studies and hands Zone projects for
practical experience just like a
demonstration we showed you just now uh
for the digital marketing just like
toast one uh there are many many many
projects which I'll be talking about in
the upcoming slides and basically how
you can take advantage of that you know
while you're taking of this program as
well so and also you get access to
online live virtual classrooms with peer
and instruction intera interaction and
also this program will be flexible to
fit your life stle and schedule in case
you are a working professional uh in
basically looking some for something you
know due to on the site uh also I think
someone asked about the program duration
of this uh program uh so the program
duration for the uh pgp program
marketing web per is eight months and
you can just complete it by giving 5 to
10 hours per week so Mark I just had a
question like uh in this this live vuk
classroom with peer and instructor
interaction what kind of experience
folks can expect like what kind of
interaction happens there is it is it
boring like is it is it interesting like
what can they expect like can you share
us any any kind of instance or a story
or your your own experience from uh you
know from the
classes well it's um you know with
always with these kind of
program programs is that you get out of
it what you're prepared to put in it
yeah and of course um if you just do the
minimum required in attending a program
like this you may um you may get your uh
your your your graduate um your
certificate but it may not give you
everything that um that is out there for
you yes so I think the best thing that
you get in the uh the program and
particularly in the live classes is the
interaction with the other students yeah
where people share their
experiences and where I share um my
experiences and we bring that to
together in a uh in a very Lively uh
Lively and engaging environment now of
course
things change very very fast in digital
marketing and it's almost impossible or
simply learn to keep the material up to
dat and they're doing a pretty good job
in that but that last couple of percent
of new things that are happening in the
digital marketing industry that is where
I come in yeah because that's where the
experience of the experts yeah like me
come in where we can give you the latest
and the greatest tools the latest and
the greatest techniques the the best um
approach yep and uh and that is what we
really uh what our students really
appreciate in in attending these courses
now there's lots of exercises in the
program yeah and you'll see later in the
slides there are fantastic case studies
and those case studies they often lead
to very engaging discussions as well
during the training program so the
interaction is um is really good um
that's my experience so far and that is
one thing that I'm very keen on
promoting in my
workshops uh thank you so much for
answering that that seems a really
interesting class to join I must say and
I think we'll be talking more about the
program in the upcoming slides uh I
think I can see few questions on the
chart here we'll be answering those like
don't worry about that we'll be covering
those as well uh so what exactly you get
from this program so you'll get a post
uh basically Purdue postgraduate
certificate here in digital Market which
you can see on your screen here and also
handson project which we already
mentioned earlier and a Capstone project
and also master classes and EMS with
Purdue and meta and also Purdue alumni
association membership uh also uh the
pur University Advantage uh so puru is a
150 year old University established by a
land grant from the state of Indiana and
this being one of the top public us
universities worldwide and also has
produced a lot of Nobel priz when us uh
so having a pero P University on CV is
definitely a prestigious accomplishment
recognized worldwide uh and moving on to
basically the meta Advantage which I
mentioned earlier as well the meta
blueprint Sprint in this meta Advantage
you'll be getting exclusive ask me
anything sessions by meta master classes
by meta experts industry recognized meta
blueprint certification exam and prep
voucher and uh the digital marketing
skills which we'll be covering in this
program which basically will be opening
a lot of career options for you not just
a digital marketing expert much more
than that uh so Mark just a question uh
there's uh basically always a zma right
like someone who's trying to basically
aspire to be a digital marketing expert
uh like usually like people are just
aware that you know okay if I go for a
digital marketing course I maybe will
become a digital marketing expert or a
digital marketing manager or something
like that right uh so but as we can see
there are so many career options here
can you take us through maybe few career
options for someone who's basically
looking out to basically just start and
they Stu in the Z like where do you
start yeah good question um by the way
before I go into that there was one um
and I think it was M cotina who made a
very good point um another answer for
the questionnaire should be difficulty
in building a portfolio yeah and that is
what I come across a lot in running the
this program with with other students in
the past is they they are new in digital
marketing yeah and they they haven't got
a portfolio yeah so so if if I go to
apply for a job I've
done hundreds of websites yeah so I've
done SEO programs I've done for many
clients I've done advertising campaigns
so I have quite a big portfolio that I
can show but when you start in digital
marketing you don't have a a portfolio
and that is I think one of the biggest
benefits and that is where simp this
program from Simply simply learn with
Purdue is clearly setting itself apart a
key differentiator in other words is
that we help you create a
portfolio yeah that you can use when you
start looking for a job in digital
marketing and the uh the Capstone
project and will come back to the
Capstone project probably in a little
bit is a great way in helping you to
achieve this as a portfolio now what you
of course if you're new to digital
marketing you'll be bombarded in this
program with new terms and new things
and as I said things are changing so
incredibly fast yeah now let me just ask
you a question yeah I've been in
marketing for 40 years and in the last
six months I have seen the biggest
change in marketing I have ever
experienced in those 40
years does anybody know what has
happened in the last six months when it
comes to digital
marketing exactly the first answer spot
on these spot on artificial
intelligence AI get
GPT is shaking Market
at its
foundations yeah it is all of a sudden I
can ask chat GPT to write a blog post
for me yeah and I can ask Chad GPT to
design an ad for me yeah which is a it
is fundamental change it's the biggest
change I have seen in digital marketing
and we don't know yet how this is going
to impact the job
market simply because there are so many
more things to come yep
so you may be studying for jobs that do
not yet
exist so keep that in mind yeah and um
and I've seen the program and uh
fortunately I think that simply learn
has updated the materials yeah and
includeed chat GPT and artificial
intelligence in the program as well so
that is um and it's very exciting yes
so uh but anyway back to the jobs and
the job market yeah for digital
marketing there's two approaches that
you can do yeah you can either be a
generalist or you can be a specialist
now
generalists are usually working for big
companies on what we say the client
sites so a generalist knows everything
about digital marketing just enough to
run it yeah so that can be uh they know
about search engine optimization they
know about website marketing about email
marketing about content marketing social
media about digital advertising yeah so
they know enough of everything to run a
digital marketing program for your own
business or for a company that you work
for as a digital marketing manager yeah
so that is a generalist and some people
want to do that yeah so and this program
can definitely turn you into a
generalist now you can also decide to
become a
specialist so then you become an SEO
Specialist or a digital analytics
Specialist or maybe a Content marketing
or a social media
specialist most often these people they
go and work for an
agency yeah and they do their specialist
services for the clients for that agency
or you work work as a specialist in
larger companies who have more the
bigger digital marketing teams and they
can afford to bring in
Specialists okay so if you yeah keep
that in mind specialist generalist
Specialists they work for agencies or
for larger digital marketing teams
generalists they work for smaller
companies or maybe even for their own
company yeah and if you then look at
what are are the
hottest places to be in digital
marketing at the moment yeah then if I
would uh with with my knowledge if I
would choose I would either specialize
in digital
analytics yeah digital analytics is a
very Hot Topic in digital marketing I
would specialize probably in uh content
marketing yeah um and content marketing
uh combined with artificial
intelligence and another hot area is
obviously um strongly developing is the
whole area of virtual reality and
augmented reality the the metaverse and
and what have
you so that brings me to a quick
overview of the program yeah the skills
that you will will
build and we will start with the um the
search engine optimization yeah what I
just showed you with the the toast case
study yeah gives you a bit of an idea of
what set play in search engine
optimization we will then go
into payperclick
advertising yes so basically search
engine optimization is free to get your
listing on Google where payperclick
advertising cost your money to buy your
position on Google or on Facebook or on
Instagram yeah both are very important
so that is a very important area that we
look at in paper paperclick and ads
testing Etc we then look at social
media yeah content marketing and we'll
dive into web analytics as well and then
there are an a number of elective
courses like email marketing and and and
a few other ones so those are kind of
the high level skills that you will
build up in this this
program uh thank you so much Ma for
taking us to the skills and the career
path uh before we move on to the tools
and platforms you'll be covering in this
program uh I think someone has asked on
the chat while you were saying you know
these are the things which hot right so
someone has asked like why content
marketing yeah that's of course that's I
like that question uh for me content is
the fuel of your digital marketing
content is the fuel of your social media
yeah it's all about really good content
yeah and well we will talk about it
extensively yeah the question before the
why content marketing is how can I get
customers now that is a very important
question yeah and you get one of the key
objectives of doing digital marketing is
to find new
customers and in today's
market bear in mind that before the
customer will talk to
you they will have done their research
online yeah and and so your challenge is
that when your potential customer
searches online about for solutions for
his
problem
or yeah yeah so uh that that before he
finds the solu where he searches for
solutions for his problems that you will
that your content will show
up yeah so because he's no longer
looking for a commercial brochure yeah
or um or a flyer or he will want an
answer to the questions that they have
yeah and if you can help him with that
yeah then you increase the chance that
they will buy from you and that's the
whole essence of content
marketing does that answer your question
uh K cook yes please do let us know in
chat here and thank you so much Ma for
answering that uh definitely an
interesting field of content marketing
and moving on to the tools and platforms
you've been learning uh in this program
as you can see so many tools here which
are covered here and I'm pretty sure
there are much more than these tools and
platforms are covered in this program
Mark maybe can you tell us a little bit
of few of these tools you know like to
start with something you know which they
can understand yeah I'm a bit of a a
tools geek yeah so um I'm constantly
looking out for new tools and the
problem is that a lot of these tools
cost money yes so and I am Dutch you
know and Dutch people are known for not
wanting to spend money yeah we're very
frugal in the Netherlands so and I
challenge myself to find tools that are
free of charge
yes so um so when you attend my workshop
then then um yeah you will get access to
a lot and a lot of tools now the nice
thing is that all the Google tools are
free yeah so there is Google
analytics yeah you see Google Keyword
Planner and Google has a lot more tools
Google ads itself is free of course you
just pay for the the ads yes so there is
the tools like all the advertising tools
but there are so many more tools out
there that are there to make your life
easy yes so there's lots of SEO tools
there's lots of content creation tools
um and of course now with the whole um
development of artificial intelligence
there tools that can help you create uh
text there are tools that can help you
create Graphics there are tools that can
help you create videos you name it for
every topic yeah like social media
content marketing Etc um I will I
probably have a 2030 tools that I will
be sharing with you in various documents
during the the the the
sessions so you'll be bom you'll be um
and then of course it's for you to
decide which tools you like because for
some people yeah they say hey I don't
like this tool I'd rather use that tool
and sometimes there are students that
they bring up tools that hey I'm I'm not
aware of yeah so I can learn as well
from
that uh thank you so much for taking us
to the tools and platforms
uh also how this program basically
builds your digital marketing skills
step by step as you can see you know
there's a pipeline of basically the
program here Mark maybe can you take us
through these steps maybe just give you
give us a little overview you know of
the yes yeah so we will start with the
basics of marketing yeah and uh which is
um uh because marketing has been around
and there are some Concepts in marketing
yeah that are that that haven't changed
over the years so we'll we'll explore
those those con Concepts and then we'll
take it into the next level where we
start looking at Mission Vision value
positioning and keywords yeah and we
talked about keywords earlier and those
keywords and your positioning that will
drive your search engine optimization
and with the search engine optimization
we will also teach you how to do that
for your own website or for somebody
else's website yeah have in this section
we will also go into how do I build my
own website once you've got your website
ready and you understand the concept of
marketing and how to win new clients we
are going to look at okay let's start
looking into advertising payperclick
advertising now why do we call this PPC
or payperclick it's basically
gold paperclick because you will only
pay for your ad yeah when somebody
clicks on it yeah and that's how how
most of these advertising platforms work
yes so um and then we're going to
measure yeah so the um what what we
achieved with our digital marketing so
web analytics is very important and then
there is the social media marketing
social media marketing is very important
we'll talk about that extensively yeah
and we look at the the all the new areas
the social media marketing and then
there are a number of elective courses
like email marketing brand management
content marketing mobile marketing you
name it there is a meta Master Class
very important where you get a blueprint
certification from Facebook um there is
a Purdue digital marketing master class
so lots of objectives that you can
choose from and then the grand finale is
your opportunity to create your own
portfolio in the digital marketing
Capstone project that's basically where
you consider yourself working for a
company and um the uh your opportunity
to put together a digital marketing
program for the company and you can use
that as an example project or a um yeah
for your uh when you go into a uh an
interview situation where they ask for
your
portfolio yep so that's taking place
step by step uh thank you so much Mark
for taking us through the steps for this
program also about the electives the
digital marketing meta Master Class the
pero digital marketing uh Master Class
the brand management Advan uh email
marketing Advanced content marketing
Advanced Mobile mobile marketing there
these are lot of electives you can cover
in this program uh so these are
completely optional they come as a part
of the program we do not charge you
anything extra for that so you don't
have to pay anything extra for that it
is uh it will be under the program fee
so it is up to you if you want to take
up those electives uh and also moving on
basically I think Mark has mentioned the
projects the projects and the case
studies you will be working on on this
program and uh you can see few projects
here I and we covered one project of
basically toast also here basically how
you can reach new customers through
digital branding and uh uh and as as
Mark said that he has basically a lot of
uh basically uh you know like keywords
you know and sets B basically he shares
with his students you know during the
program as well and also there are many
more other projects with real business
applications you can share to your
future basically employees uh so
basically I I think this is mentioned
before that uh if you come from a
non-digital marketing background and uh
you do not have an experience in that so
having these projects on your portfolio
definitely enhances your chances for
getting a job uh and also obviously it
is up to for you to choose if you want
to be a journalist or a specialist I
think that is something was made pretty
clear uh moving on uh the Capstone
projects the Capstone projects you can
showcase to your future employees as
well apart from the projects which we
industry projects we have we also have
CST projects we can work on and these
cap student projects are built in a way
that mimics real business scenarios for
true life experience uh and you can
choose there are basically five projects
you can choose one out of those five
projects you know as for your preference
uh which you would want to basically
work on and showcase to your future
employes uh now I just have a quick
question mark for you how does having a
Capstone project on your basically
resume uh when you're coming from a
completely uh different background uh
and you don't have an experience also
digital marketing how how does having a
caption project in projects which
basically which this program covers
which I've shown earlier uh how does it
help how does it help when you basically
are trying to build your
portfolio well um of course you won't do
this you will only be able to do this
Capstone project at the end of the eight
month program yeah so you've then built
up you've learned all the new things in
digital marketing and you are then able
to do the Capstone project Okay so
and then of course the reality is if you
are going to start looking for a
job you don't have any work
experience yeah so there's nothing that
you can show that you've done realtime
work in digital marketing but what you
can show is that you understand all the
aspects from in in related to digital
marketing and you manage to capture that
in your Capstone projects yeah and your
Capstone project is nothing else than a
presentation yeah that you can show to
your prospective employer about that
case study where you've implemented all
the things in a in a in a lab
environment yeah so in not in a real
life environment but at least you've
shown that you've done it in a learning
environment so that's better than
nothing yes so that's um and that's what
I like about the Capstone project it is
you have some practical sort of um
materials in your hand yeah and that
could be in the Capstone project you
will design a couple of Facebook ads M
yeah and you will um done a simple
keyword
analysis yeah and you have created a few
Instagram
posts yeah and not only that but that is
part of an overall digital marketing
strategy to launch a new brand in a
particular
Market yeah so there is stuff that you
can show to your prospective employer
yeah and and that is stuff that you will
be doing in a live environment for them
when they employ
you uh thank you so much Mark I think
that gives a little bit idea about the
capson projects and projects how you
basically can use that in your portfolio
uh when you're trying to get out there
after the program and trying to get job
ready give interviews uh prepare your
resumes uh also um in this program we
have global leaders and as program
advisers uh just
and Brad G is Matt Bailey uh being one
of the grobal leaders here they make
sure that simply learn is delivering as
for the standards of Pur and also uh we
have a job assist uh program for India
and us only I'll be sharing the program
link for your region on the chat here
once I'll be sharing the program Fe you
in the schedule uh so we have uh this in
Partnerships with I am jobs in India and
tting in the US so and in this we
provide resume building assistance
Career Mentoring with and interview
preparation sessions with your webinars
and career Affairs as well uh so the
eligibility and PR sites for this one I
think someone asked about this uh for
someone basically who has a lot of
experience uh is this program valid so
uh the first eligibility criteria here
is you may have a non marketing
background it's that is the one and a
bachelor's degree in is required and you
need at least two years of work
experience of you know for basically
taking of this program so uh I think we
have one question
uh in in basically the Q&A box will take
we'll take up that uh
Mark okay uh basically it's a very basic
question like how to start in digital
marketing and how to yeah how to start
in digital marketing yes um okay the
first thing I would do in uh when you
start in digital marketing is start
Market
yourself yes
so build your own website build your own
resume website get on LinkedIn build
your LinkedIn profile yeah and when you
build your own website yeah it's uh I'll
show you can I quickly share my screen
yeah yeah please please so see if the
site is
live desktop also Mark uh we will just
extend the session by 5 to 7 minutes
more is that okay
yeah yeah so if I go to mark campman
docomo my prospective employer if I
would look for a job about hey this is
my my my online profile I got a website
I've optimized it for SEO yeah so that
is a great way to start
yeah there is a section about about me
my resume my portfolio and my blog yeah
so here you click on view more that
takes you to the about me yeah and
everything I teach I talk about here as
well yeah so you have my resume you have
some stuff about my
portfolio I think the website looks
pretty cool the interface yeah yeah yeah
so and you don't need to work for
another company yeah to uh to do this
this is your own sort of presentation
where you can immediately show that you
understand digital marketing if you want
to take it a step further start
blogging yeah now I've blocked for many
years but what I also did is actually I
started
podcasting oh interesting can you share
the link with us on chat I'm pretty sure
the folks would like to check it out
yeah so here is actually a podcast is
how to optimize your website for
search yes so I will uh put that in the
in the
zoom where is the
chat to everyone so here is the link to
an SEO podcast I
did so yes so
again when I do this and when I sit at a
client and present
myself this tells them hey yeah Mark
knows what he's doing
yeah exactly it's it's a very good first
impression to have right
yeah I think uh in this program also
we'll be helping you build a really good
portfolio as well so uh you can check
out marks portfolio as well this is a
really really cool website to have I'm
pretty sure like I'm taking inspiration
from this now so very motivated to
create my own as well and I think I've
shared the podcast link here as well if
that helps you they can check out the
podcast and support that as well let me
just quickly share back my screen and
we're talking about the eligibility and
requisites uh so uh we have talked about
the projects we have talked about the
skills we have talked about the career
Parts uh and we have talked about
basically the project demonstration you
you'll be basically getting out of uh
this program and many more case studies
you'll be covering this program which
you can take up and add to your
portfolio and also an amazing Capstone
project we can you can showcase to your
future employees which will completely
enhance your profile uh coming from a
different background coming from a
similar marketing background trying to
basically upscale so we would like to
know are you interested in enrolling
into the puru postgraduate program IND
digal marketing so you can see a quick
PLL in your screen while I was speaking
we have gotten almost half of the word
so that's great
uh but I would want other other folks
also uh to basically uh quickly just go
to through go through this wall here and
we would love to know that are you
interested in enrolling to the
postgraduate program in arktic by pum
and uh I can see we have few questions
on the Q&A box here uh we have exceeded
the time by 10 minutes and uh thank you
I would thank Mark for that for G you
know exing the time uh but I I can see
the demand by the audience here as well
you know there were a lot of questions
and we actually took a lot of questions
you know throughout the session itself
so we actually don't have many questions
left in the Q&A box as well in a little
less time uh so we'll try to try to take
questions please go and add your
questions in the Q&A box if you have any
questions we will just have few more
minutes meanwhile you can see a quick
call in your screen here I'll be talking
about the program schedule and the
program fee and how you can enroll into
the program after this so I'll just keep
this PO live for 10 seconds more uh for
a few of the folks who have yet to
basically share their interest about the
program so uh please go and check out
the poll which you see on your screen
right now so are you interested in
enrolling to the postgraduate program
dist marketing by P and uh also uh while
uh you guys are basically uh voting here
on the poll about the enrollment here
there are very quick options there yes
or no you can share your interest
towards the enrollment also just to let
you know for attending this webinar
you'll be getting a bonus offer as well
for basically joining the program so why
miss out on that right just just go and
check out the program and enroll it and
also what I will do is I will quickly
share the link for the program here as
well uh for you to check out much more
details about the program so you can
check out the program in much more
detail even after the session here and
uh also if you have any questions you
can always uh reach out to us at ask
us.net
and also uh we have so many much uh
webinars you know which are upcoming in
the month of towards the October and
noral December uh you can basically
learn and grow and join the excitement
of our live master classes you can check
out these links here as well so I think
I'll just give five seconds more uh for
this poll here meanwhile I can
see uh basically a few questions coming
in on the Q&A box let me see which we
can take up you know while you guys are
basically posting uh your answer here on
the poll
here
okay oh interesting question we've
gotten one interesting question question
I think it'll take one question towards
the end I think I'll just give 5 Seconds
more for the poll here so few of the
folks who basically are still voting for
the poll here I'll just be closing that
in 5 seconds to please do not miss out
on the bonus offer you will be getting
for attend this webinar for this program
uh and uh so 5 4 3 2 1 I'll end the poll
and uh basically I saw a lot of interest
towards enrollment so that's great
that's positive uh moving on to through
the enrollment steps uh so the it's
basically very three easy steps you need
to follow you basically need to submit
an application and the application will
be going for a review uh based on your
qualifications eligibility criteria and
based on that you'll be getting an
admissions call from Simply learns
learning consultant uh for the cohut the
introductory class for the this this
particular program will be on October
20th and uh the classes will be starting
from December second and uh basically we
can see prices here for us candidates
$3,000 USD this include taxes and for
Indian Cates it is 1 lakh
1,999 uh INR and including GST uh taxes
uh for folks who have joined from
different uh uh basically uh basically
countries apart from uh us and India I'm
sharing the link of the program once
here again you can check out the program
fee uh for your on region here and as I
said that you can always reach out to us
for more assistance uh at as at s.net
I'm just sharing it once again here in
case you have any questions you can mail
mail us uh there and also uh see we have
very limited seats per cohart uh we only
take 25 to 30 folks per cohart uh and
also we do this because we want to make
sure that you getting all the attention
that is required while you're taking up
this program so uh basically you have a
good great experience while you're
learning dig marketing with us and
moving on uh for folks who have already
shared basically uh interest towards
enrollment uh we would want to know how
soon do you plan to enroll into the
postc program in digital marketing by
Pur you can see four quick options on
the poll here I've launched a quick poll
here and uh you can see four quick
options here immediately within three
months within six months and the last
one more than six months not please do
let us know this will give us a better
idea uh basically what kind of U
basically enrollment month are you
looking at you know when basically are
you planning to join uh so please do let
us know uh on this quick poll here this
will basically give us an idea when
basically to reach out to you with the
admissions off a letter uh and also u in
case you're still thinking about it but
interested so I would suggest to take up
the within six months or more than six
months option uh because the bonus offer
of this webinar basically why lose out
on that right so take take up that bonus
offer and keep the basically enrollment
uh maybe from within 6 months or more
than six months off if you're still
thinking about it still planning it out
I would recommend those options for
folks who have already shared the
interest towards enrollment uh you can
choose up like immediately or within
three months or something which is the
most suitable for you from the four
options here so I'll just give five
seconds more for this poll and we'll
just end it so five 4 3 2
one thank you so much for sharing with
us when do you plan to enroll now coming
to the Q&A part of the session so while
we were talking about the program uh we
basically have gotten a very interesting
uh question here as well I think that is
something Mark has already answered so
I'll just read out the question and the
answer as well uh so I think Alan has
asked like hello Mr Mark U I will ask
you a question about yourself which one
biggest regret in is in your digital
marketing career which one is the big
biggest regret in your digital marketing
career do you have any tips what we
should avoid exactly in digital
marketing and Mark has responded that
don't think in regret it's I think
positive big thing learn every day so uh
I think that is a response from that one
and uh basically we have actually
covered a lot of questions throughout
the session and also extended the
session by 15 minutes so so sorry folks
we'll be uh basically ending the session
now uh we are towards the end of the
session and uh we would like to thank ma
before that I'll just launch a quick
poll on just to understand if you need
assistance in enrolling to the program
you can see a quick pull on your screen
uh this is for the folks who have
already shared interest and also have
let us know how soon do you plan to
enroll uh so if you need assistance you
can click on yes uh if you don't need
assistance you can click on no this is a
very quick poll I'll just keep it live
for 10 seconds uh I would say get the
extra help you're getting right why not
like why not take a you know much more
detailed walkth through the program uh
so while we will be reaching out to you
will make sure basically you get much
more detailed work through of the
program as well from Simply lears
learning consultant so uh please like uh
basically tell us if you need assistance
uh for the program and I'll just uh keep
this full life for 5 seconds more and uh
thank you so much for being a great
audience uh and we have gotten many
interesting questions from you and we
have answered a lot of them as well
throughout the session and we basically
are towards the end of the session so
thank you so much everyone for joining
thank you so much Mark uh for basically
taking us to the project demonstration
and also answering uh so many
interesting questions and also giving a
bits about your digital marketing career
as well would you like to see something
to the crowd before we end the
session yeah what I said in the answer
is um of the last Q&A session question
is um learn every day yeah my I live by
the excitement I get get give my
students to learn yeah so um even if you
learn every day a little bit if you add
it all together you learn a lot in a
year yes
so uh take this opportunity folks learn
learn learn because when you learn you
grow when you learn you learn new things
and when you learn you get out of your
comfort zone and you go into new
territories so that's the best advice I
can give you yeah is um develop Yourself
by learning learning every
day well that's pretty inspiring what
ating I'm feeling motivated for sure I
would love to know from you folks how
are you feeling and how was the session
on chat here uh please do let us know uh
we'll be ending the session now I'll
just uh keep like two minutes more for
the folks here if you would like to see
anything on the chat here how was the
session for you uh how was the
experience would you like to see
something to Mark here please do let us
know on chat here and uh we tried
covering all the questions possible
through the session but if you have any
questions you can always reach out to us
at ask us at simply land.net uh we'll be
covering coming up with a lot of
interesting sessions and uh many
interesting sessions with Mark as well
in the coming months so you'll get to
see him as well uh so I can see
responses coming in on chat here so
thank you uh and informative experience
it was a really awesome session awesome
webinar very helpful so thank you so
much folks uh thank you for the
appreciation and once again thanks Mark
for joining us and taking us to the free
digital marketing master class and uh
we'll be ending the session now and uh
have a good evening good night uh
wherever you're joining us from good
morning thank you thank you so
much
bye-bye